[Music]
one fine day when Charles Darwin was
still a student at Cambridge the budding
naturalist tore some old bark off a tree
and found two rare beetles underneath
he'd just taken one beetle in each hand
when he spotted a third beetle stashing
one of the insects in his mouth for
safekeeping he reached for the new
specimen when a sudden spray of hot
bitter fluid scalded his tongue
Darwin's assailant was the bombardier
beetle it's one of thousands of animal
species like frogs and jellyfish
salamanders and snakes that use toxic
chemicals to defend themselves in this
case by spewing poisonous liquid from
glands in its abdomen but why doesn't
this caustic substance ejected at 100
degrees Celsius hurt the beetle itself
in fact how do any toxic animals survive
their own secretions the answer is that
they use one of two basic strategies
securely storing these compounds or
evolving resistance to them bombardier
beetles use the first approach they
store ingredients for their poison in
two separate chambers when they're
threatened the valve between the
chambers opens and the substances
combine in a violent chemical reaction
that sends a corrosive spray shooting
out of the glands passing through a
hardened chamber that protects the
beetles internal tissues similarly
jellyfish packaged their Venom's safely
in harpoon-like structures called
nematocysts and venomous snakes store
their flesh-eating blood clotting
compounds in specialized compartments
that only have one exit through the
fangs and into their prey or predator
snakes also employ the second strategy
built in biochemical resistance
rattlesnakes and other types of Vipers
manufacture special proteins that bind
and inactivate venom components in the
blood
meanwhile poison dart frogs have also
evolved resistance to their own toxins
but through a different mechanism these
tiny animals defend themselves using
hundreds of bitter tasting compounds
called alkaloids that they accumulate
from consuming small arthropods like
mites and ants one of their most potent
alkaloids is the chemical epi betadine
which binds to the same receptors in the
brain as nicotine but is at least ten
times stronger an amount barely heavier
than a grain of sugar would kill you so
what prevents poison frogs from
poisoning themselves think of the
molecular target of a neurotoxic
alkaloid as a lock and the alkaloid
itself as the key when the toxic key
slides into the lock it sets off a
cascade of chemical and electrical
signals that can cause paralysis
unconsciousness and eventually death but
if you change the shape of the lock the
key can't fit for poison dart frogs and
many other animals with neurotoxic
defenses a few genetic changes alter the
structure of the alkaloid binding site
just enough to keep the neurotoxin from
exerting its adverse effects poisonous
and venomous animals aren't the only
ones that can develop this resistance
their predators and prey can - the
garter snake which dines on neurotoxic
salamanders has evolved resistance to
salamander toxins through some of the
same genetic changes as the salamanders
themselves that means that only the most
toxic salamanders can avoid being eaten
and only the most resistant snakes will
survive the meal the result is that the
genes providing the highest resistance
and toxicity will be passed on in
greatest quantities to the next
generations as toxicity ramps up
resistance does - in an evolutionary
arms race that plays out over millions
of years this pattern appears over and
over again grasshopper mice resist
painful venom from scorpion prey through
genetic changes in their nervous systems
horned lizards readily consume harvest
ants resisting there in venom to sting
with specialized blood plasma and sea
slugs eat jellyfish new motto cysts
prevent their activation with compounds
in their mucus and repurpose them for
their own defenses the bombardier beetle
is no exception the toads that swallow
them can tolerate the caustic spray that
Darwin found so distasteful most of the
beetles are spit up hours later
amazingly alive and well but how do the
toads survive the experience that is
still a mystery haven't had your fill
pick your poison with one of these two
lessons
[Music]